ou madame l'infirmière oui c'est moi qui
vous appelez oui il faudrait que
j'écrive à ma femme
1 bah oui tu encore avoir du mal bon ça
vous ennuierait pas d'écrire à ma place
je vous dictez merci ma chérie eux
bah oui je suis pro moderne c'est de
l'hôpital que je t'écris pour te dire
que tout est très bien pour moi bien sûr
je ne serais pas auprès de toi pour le
15 ou mais je pense que d'ici noël
je serai remis de mes nombreuses
fractures moi quand je suis sorti du
coma j'ai appris avec surprise que tu
n'étais jamais venu me voir et que tu
n'avais même pas demandé de mes
nouvelles études disent prêtes
je suis sûr que tu avais déjà oublié ce
qui m'était arrivé points par contre
quand l'inter ne pas téléphoner et que
tu lui a répondu il peut toujours crever
son minable
là je crois que tu exagères tu n'avais
pas le droit de parler comme ça surtout
devant un étranger je sais bien que nous
nous étions chamailler la veille que
j'avais eu le tort d'élever la voix
enfin ponctuellement mais quand même
c'est pas beau de boue des points
d'exclamation l'assureur m'a écrit pour
me dire que j'étais responsable de
l'accident
vu que je n'étais pas en état de
conduire à cause des coups de marteau
que tu m'avais donné sur tu parles comme
si je n'en avais pas l'habitude
il est vrai que lui ne connais pas ton
caractère emporté mois de suspension
le commissaire affirme que c'est toi qui
a saboté la direction de ma voiture
les voisins sont vus en train de scier
mon volant alors là je m'insurge
tu sais comme je tiens à mes affaires
tu n'avais pas le droit de toucher à ma
voiture c'est une grande indélicatesses
si tout continue comme ça je finirai par
croire que tu ne m'aimes plus voilà c
est meme pas de formules de politesse
qu'est-ce qu'il vous est fixé